okay this is a question that i've
thought about
wiley lafferty asks
who are the government people that come
to confiscate cameras and data
threatening witnesses to remain silent
about their experience this has happened
to military and civilian witnesses
he says a tip question mark
no it wasn't a chip i mean no it wasn't
it but but yeah there were people who
definitely
who definitely uh try to intimidate
people and um you know all i gotta say
is you know i
that wouldn't be wise to do it with me
and my colleagues um
you know i i
i don't get intimidated very easily um
you know we're kind of the people who if
if you focus we're gonna poke you right
back
um
you know uh
i i don't know why people got
intimidated in the past um
you know the only way i would ever shut
up from this is someone really came in
and said luke we need you to
to be quiet it's hard to national
security but that hasn't happened
um
you know i'm the kind of guy if you try
to intimidate me
you're you're
you're making a big big mistake
um
and i'll leave it at that because my
background is is specific enough where
um you better come at me with everything
you got
is there any truth to men in black
well i mean sure the question is who are
they you know there's been elements in
the past where
you know us investigators um i mean the
truth is we wear black suits sometimes i
mean i have three of them you know um
the problem is that hollywood is kind of
portrayed a certain way
um
you know for us you know black suits
were fairly functional you could you
could look i mean this is going to sound
silly but you know you wear them because
they're like wearing jeans but formal
attire because you can spill food on
black suits and all that kind of stuff
and kind of wipe it away and you know
it's a little bit more forgiving than
another type of suit
so and historically they tend to be more
the cheaper suits um just because
they're black they're not you know
really fancy material or stuff like that
so historically black suits have always
been synonymous with government
and and you know what people refer to us
as government stiffs um
there's always been men in black you
know
i was one of them i was a
counterintelligence special agent but
i never intimidate intimidated people
like that um and so the question is
who's doing that and and why are they
doing that and under whose authority are
they doing that
that's my problem you know if they're
operating with without any authority
then you know
[Music]
you got problems
you know because you know we had to all
operate under under rules and
authorities and if you're not and you're
running rogue and you're going around
intimidating people you know i i can't
stand bullies man i i'm i don't like
bullies i'm not that guy anybody who
knows about the way i was raised and
what i had to go through
you know i tend to be a bit of an
anti-bully um i tend to try to
believe the bullies
yeah you know that's that's
that's kind of or put the bullies in
their place
yeah you know they weren't going to be
bullies much longer i can assure you